there was a day about 10 years ago when
I asked a friend to hold a baby dinosaur
robot upside down it was this toy called
a plio that I had ordered and I was
really excited about it because I've
always loved robots and this one has
really cool technical features it had
motors and touch sensors and it had an
infrared camera and one of the things
that had was a tilt sensor so it knew
what direction it was facing and when
you held it upside down it would start
to cry and I thought this was super cool
so I was showing it off to my friend and
I said hold it up by the tail see what
it does
so we're watching the theatrics of this
robot struggle and cry out and after a
few seconds it starts to bother me a
little and I said ok that's enough now
let's put him back down and then I pet
the robot to make it stop crying and
that was kind of a weird experience for
me for one thing I wasn't the most
maternal person at the time although
since then I've become a mother nine
months ago and I've learned that babies
also score him when you hold him upside
down but my response to this robot was
also interesting because I knew exactly
how this machine worked and yet I still
felt compelled to be kind to it and that
observation sparked a curiosity that
I've spent the fat the past decade
pursuing why did I comfort this robot
and one of the things I discovered was
that my treatment of this machine was
more than just an awkward moment in my
living room that in a world where were
increasingly integrating robots into our
lives an instinct like that might
actually have consequences
because the first thing that I
discovered is that it's not just me
in 2007 the Washington Post reported
that the United States military was
testing this robot that diffused
landmines and the way it worked was it
was shaped like a stick insect and you
would walk around a minefield on its
legs and every time it stepped on a mine
one of the legs would blow up and it
would continue on the other legs to blow
up more mines and the colonel who was in
charge of this testing exercise ends up
calling it off
because he says it's too inhumane to
watch this damage of robot drag itself
along the minefield
now what would cause a hardened military
officer and someone like myself to have
this response to robots well of course
we're primed by science fiction and pop
culture to really want to personify
these things but it goes a little bit
deeper than that it turns out that we're
biologically hardwired to project intent
and life onto any movement in our
physical space that seems autonomous to
us so people will treat all sorts of
robots like they're alive these bomb
disposal units get names they get medals
of honor they've had funerals for them
with gun salutes and research shows that
we do this even with very simple
household robots like the Roomba vacuum
cleaner just a disk that roams around
your floor to clean it which is the fact
that it's moving around on its own will
cause people to name the Roomba and feel
bad for the Rumbo when it gets stuck
under the couch and we can design robots
specifically to evoke this response
using eyes and faces or movements that
people automatically subconsciously
associate with states of mind and
there's an entire body of research
called human robot interaction that
really shows how well this works so for
example researchers at Stanford
University found out that it makes
people really uncomfortable when you ask
them to touch a robot's private parts
so from this but from many other studies
we know we know that people respond to
the cues given to them by these lifelike
machines even if they know that they're
not real now we're headed towards a
world where robots are everywhere
robotic technology is moving out from
behind factory walls it's entering
workplaces households and as these
machines that can sense and make
autonomous decisions and learn enter
into these shared spaces I think that
may be the best analogy we have for this
is our relationship with animals
thousands of years ago we started to
domesticate animals and we trained them
for work and weaponry and companionship
and throughout history we've treated
some animals like tools or like products
and other animals we've treated with
kindness and we've given a place in
society as our companions I think it's
plausible we might start to integrate
robots in similar ways and sure animals
are alive robots are not and I can tell
you from working with roboticists that
we're pretty far away from developing
robots that can feel anything but we
feel for them and that matters because
if we're trying to integrate robots into
these shared spaces we need to
understand that people will treat them
differently than other devices and that
in some cases for example the case of a
soldier who becomes emotionally attached
to the robot that they work with that
can be anything from inefficient to
dangerous
but in other cases it can actually be
useful to foster this emotional
connection to robots we're already
seeing some great use cases for example
robots working with autistic children to
engage them in ways that we haven't seen
previously or robots working with
teachers to engage kids in learning with
new results and it's not just for kids
early studies show that robots can help
doctors and patients and health care
settings this is the Paro baby seal
robot it's used in nursing homes and
with dementia patients it's been around
for a while and I remember
years ago being at a party and telling
someone about this robot and her
response was oh my gosh that's horrible
I can't believe we're giving people
robots instead of human care and this is
a really common response and I think
it's absolutely correct because that
would be terrible
but in this case it's not what this
robot replaces what this robot replaces
is animal therapy in contexts where we
can't use real animals but we can use
robots because people will consistently
treat them like more more like an animal
than a device acknowledging this
emotional connection to robots can also
help us anticipate challenges as these
devices move into more intimate areas of
people's lives for example is it okay if
your child's teddy bear robot records
private conversations is it okay if your
sex robot has compelling in-app
purchases because robots bless
capitalism equals questions around
consumer protection and privacy and
those aren't the only reasons that our
behavior around these machines could
matter a few years after that first
initial experience I had with this baby
dinosaur robot I did a workshop with my
friend Hannes Gossett and we took five
of these baby dinosaur robots and we
gave them to five teams of people and we
had them name them and play with them
and interact with them for about an hour
and then we unveiled a hammer and a
hatchet and we told them to torture and
kill the robots and this turned out to
be a little more dramatic than we
expected it to be because none of the
participants would even so much as
strike these baby dinosaur robots so we
had to improvise a little and at some
point we said okay you can save your
team's robot if you destroy another
team's robot
and even that didn't work they couldn't
do it
so finally we said we're gonna destroy
all of the robots
unless someone takes a hatchet to one of
them and this guy stood up and he took
the hatchet and the whole room winced as
he brought the hatchet down on the
robot's neck and there was this half
joking half serious moment of silence in
the room for this fallen robot so that
was a really interesting experience now
it wasn't a controlled study obviously
but it did lead to some later research
that I did at MIT with pelage Nandi and
Cynthia Brazil where we had people come
into the lab and smashed these hex bugs
that move around in a really lifelike
way like insects so instead of choosing
something cute that people are drawn to
we chose something more basic and what
we found was that high embassy people
would hesitate more to hit the hex bugs
now this is just a little study but it's
part of a larger body of research that
is starting to indicate that there may
be a connection between people's
tendencies for empathy and their
behavior around robots but my question
for the coming era of human robot
interaction is not do we empathize with
robots it's can robots change people's
empathy is there reason to you for
example prevent your child from kicking
a robotic dog not just out of respect
for property but because the child might
be more likely to kick a real dog and
again it's not just kids this is the
violent videogames question but it's on
a completely new level because of this
visceral physicality that we respond
more intensely to than to images on a
screen when we behave violently towards
robots specifically robots that are
designed to mimic life is that a healthy
outlet for violent behavior or is that
training or cruelty muscles we don't
know
the answer this question has the
potential to impact human behavior it
has the potential to impact social norms
it has the potential to inspire rules
around what we can and can't do with
certain robots similar to our animal
cruelty laws because even if robots
can't feel our behavior towards them
might matter for us and regardless of
whether we end up changing our rules
robots might be able to help us come to
a new understanding of ourselves most of
what I've learned over the past 10 years
has not been about technology at all
it's been about human psychology and
empathy and how we relate to others
because when a child is kind to a Roomba
when a soldier tries to save a robot on
the battlefield or when a group of
people refuses to harm a robotic baby
dinosaur those robots aren't just motors
and gears and algorithms they're
reflections of our own humanity thank
you
[Applause]